is that your business is just that
making that five thousand dollars every
time you sell a home or is there some
bigger plan here
so uh that's part of our business uh we
have a pretty large
institutional business as well ah cause
that's about to say that first business
sounds good
but not great so tell me about this
institutional business there are a
million
uh single-family rental home trades a
year ah okay
and uh out of the five million homes
that sell a year a million of them are
two investors
and so there's there's three trillion of
single-family rental homes
so it's a massive you mentioned market
size earlier
so but residential housing is the
largest asset class arguably in the
world
at 25 trillion dollars the single family
rental home act
with long-term leases in it is about 3
trillion so
that is a massive market so so the
retail market
we think has enormous potential to
disrupt
the way the traditional assets trade
on the institutional side the majority
of our business today is actually
institutional
where we represent either large
institutional
owners who want to sell big portfolios
or
institutional capital wants to build
their own portfolios and they can plug
into our system
and use it to either build their own or
sell their portfolio very efficiently
because we've
we know who all the buyers and sellers
are as a marketplace so we could very
efficiently help them make those trades
and so
and on the institutional side we'll
charge you know more like one percent
on a 100 million dollar transaction
where we'll charge say three percent on
a 100 000
house so that's the way it works